then congratulations how you feeling
this morning
thank you I'm great I head into Philly
right now so no way to get there what
position do you want to play in the NBA
0.44 sure I think that's the best
position for me in my style of play I
think I can get them playing a portfolio
is that now an official position because
they put up PF last night as if power
forward is what you're listed as and
they said it's either a point forward or
a point guard but I don't see as a power
forward right I think it's turning into
a new position in the game but you know
obviously can't be listed so I think
overall more of a point got played
forward through some that's where I want
to be could you have played right out of
high school in the NBA well I'd like to
try try because the system is that you
have to go to school for a year right
did it help you that much going to LSU I
think you helped me level than anything
just playing to adversity and and
knowing I think I'll be perfect
I think that was the biggest thing for
me when did you get better than your dad
when did you realize you were better at
basketball and a new dad I think when I
was 15 I came back to Australia off my
sophomore year I was 16 and finally you
know played on one one and beat him so I
think that was a day I really you know
got that win how was dinner that night
though after you beat you dad the knock
you hear and you're gonna continue to
hear is well he's got to work on his
shot how do you you're gonna hear you
know you have to work on your shot you
know he does all these things but he
doesn't have he doesn't have a great
shot how do you answer that as you go
into your rookie year I'm working on
everything right now but the time I get
to Liddy I believe you know I'll be a
much better player than I was the other
day so every day I'm getting better and
working very hard Jay Bilas was just on
he said the LSU staff wanted you to
shoot threes but you didn't why I think
it was more of a thing where we I got
straight so I didn't feel the need to
take his money
I can definitely shoot the ball so that
wasn't the problem but I think you know
I was just trying to make sure no we
were getting the best out of each player
when's the last time you talked to
LeBron James last night actually uh my
uh get together What did he say
he said congratulations and you know I
told him I was looking forward to
finally matching up against in the
preseason What did he say about that I
put the camera and it was the
championship trophy so I couldn't say
whose posters did you have on your walls
growing up I had Allen Iverson a banner
of Allen Oz and hanging on my door have
you talked to Iverson not yet I'm
looking forward to talking some we're
getting some advice
so not kind of wait for that was there
now what happened prior to the draft a
couple of weeks prior where it felt like
you wanted to go to Los Angeles or
somebody speaking on your behalf
wanted wanted you to end up in Los
Angeles because of the opportunities
there what what was there any true to
that story no I think that was more
immediate thing that this shows you can
really believe everything you read or
see unless it's coming from that person
but no definitely you know I'm very very
happy to be going to Philly
he's been Simmons the 76ers rookie how
did you guys not make the NCAA
tournament just not winning you know a
lot of players were heard a lot of
chemistry that was broken because guys
were out and it kind of makes messed
things up but um I definitely enjoy my
time there I love LSU love the people
there the fans some great fans and the
coaches wouldn't trade for anything what
number are you going to have with the
76ers
oh so you gonna stay with that what is
that why twenty-five why did you pick
that in the first place
that's a family nobody
desmona my brothers my sister so
definitely want to keep the family
that's cool
hey safe travels and congratulations
thank her again alright Ben Simmons
76ers rookie the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience